[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone and welcome to our charity
stream foreplay for all this Monday June
22nd it's June right I was about to say
July it's definitely still June hi I'm
chastity from gamespot universe and I'm
joined by my whole team of the editorial
GameSpot University Plus Ryan from the
GameSpot universe video team so if
you've ever read something about
entertainment in terms of movies TV
wrestling anime chances are one of the
people here wrote that and Ryan does
videos on American Horror Story and all
sorts of other things hey guys thanks
for joining me today we're gonna do some
trivia are you ready we are doing trivia
I spent all day Friday making questions
and very excited I skipped lunch because
I was so in the zone
I'm got a lot of questions for y'all I
think I made like 180 questions but the
chats also know I get involved to you I
am here in the YouTube chat watching you
guys but none of the people on the panel
are allowed to look at the chat because
the chat will probably have the answers
up quickly as well so the thing is if no
one gets the answer right for any of
these questions for that question the
chat will get at the point if they get
it right and then if the chat gets the
point right I will donate to both causes
we are donating to black lives matter
and to Cove in nineteen relief efforts
so and then I will have that matched by
CBS so that's a little incentive on the
chats part and for you guys just good
luck it's gonna be 90s and 2000's trivia
for this stream and I've got got a Divya
divvied up in some categories we've got
horror
we've got super here
comic book movies and we've got action
movies from the 90's and 2000's for our
main categories and then we're gonna
have two lightning rounds at towards the
end of the stream which are gonna be
movie posters where I'm going to show
you a zoomed in portion of the movie
poster they're gonna be all genres from
1992 to 2010 and you have to recognize
the poster that it is and call that out
and then movie tag lines will be the
second lightning round
I've got like 40 of those also from 1990
to 2010 I will read a movie tagline and
you have to identify the movie so to
buzz in we're not a fancy system you are
going to call out your name like a
Pokemon and it'll be great
so please call out your first name or
last name but just stay consistent so I
can keep track of that and then I will
keep score but if I mess up the score or
anything please just shout me out on
chat and also just so you guys know we
are collecting donations to black lives
matter and Cove in nineteen relief
efforts through direct relief those
links should be in the description below
yes they are so please click on those
links and donate during the stream and
help us with those great causes all
right are you guys ready for some trivia
cool all right here we go
Harley says I stand medic so Maggie
you've got some support in the chat
alright cool
we've got movie trivia so you guys in
the chat are also involved in this to
you I am on twitch and I am on YouTube
so I can see those chats right now so
thanks for joining us by the way all
right here we go so we're gonna start
with horror 90's and 2000's horror is
the first category all right so I'll
have you guys vote first you guys on the
panel want to do name the movie from the
cast or name the movie from the synopsis
first easy guys in out that I was a
child in the 90s I made sure that I had
heard of all of these and I'm not that
much older than you I think all right
here we go so it's gonna be named the
movie from the synopsis the category is
Horrors to think about horror movies I
say the word [ __ ]
weird cuz I'm from New York and I moved
to California so if I keep saying it and
it sounds weird every single time that
is why anyway I also do that with the
word water named the movie from the
synopsis here's number one ready here we
go alright
natives of a small Isle isolated town
defend themselves against strange
underground creatures which are killing
them one by one so my name tremors and
is corrects my gear on the boat I've got
something for everyone I promise you
okay very good start okay number two
after a teenager has a terrifying vision
of him and his friends dying in a plane
crash he prevents the accident final
final destination correct very nice you
know you're very close meg was ahead by
like half a second alright um here we go
number three Oh Thank You Brandon for
telling you my pleasure dolls are cute
yes I have a nice collection here I
bought the life-size Psyduck i
pre-ordered it and it's coming late 2020
so I'm really excited for my son to come
home but he's also my son your great
alright alright number three here we go
a journalist must investigate a
mysterious videotape which seems to
cause an offering elf ring ring that is
correct
[Laughter]
final destination everybody beat me so I
was just ready to be defeated oh I just
thought that's how you felt about the
ring about myself apparently the rare
Ringu which was better
Ringu way scarier yeah yeah way scarier
what he did no sir no way hey Martina
thanks for joining us oh we got some
friends here and Nick Sherman's here
alright cool thanks for supporting us
all right
hey that's the grudge did the ring have
sarah michelle gellar the grudge
ring had Naomi Watts this is gonna be a
nightmare
[Laughter]
alright okay here we go
number four Jason Voorhees returns with
a new letter machete
retainers Jason axe baby as Mike just
watched tremors I just rewatched Jason
axe it's so bad oh man it says Ringu the
book I didn't know there was a book
should I read bring through the book
that sounds great I will have to check
that out for sure okay
and hello to the twitch chat I'm here
now with you they got tremors and they
got the ring they got Jason X good job
shout-out to Punisher and word 789 for
getting Jason X but that was really
impressive Chris here we go next
question an investigative reporter must
send the newly unbound pinhead and his
legions back to hell it's a Hellraiser I
don't know that you have to say the
correct one Ryan wait to guess which one
it is oh hell raisers 3-cd and Barbie
and Hellraiser 3 hell on earth
that's the token according to IMDB
alright
I thought because 4 is 1 in space I
thought that was 5 I was lucky just
getting it doing well right now good job
guys
Harley said Meg you got this alright
here we go and then we will be checking
it on donations after this segment ok so
please guys the donation links are in
the chat if you just joined us we are
donating to black lives matter and to
copa90 and Direct Relief those links are
in the description below please help us
raise money for those great causes and
we are doing 90s and 2000's trivia so
thanks for joining us alright we are on
to number 6 two strangers who awaken in
a room with
recollection of how they died painter
saw correct never seen it I don't okay
here we go
very good number seven a man is
accidentally transported to 1380 where
he must battle an army of the Dead it's
like bum to have the correct answer
[Laughter]
alright if you notice there are some
dogs on the stream today we've got a dog
behind Mike and we've got a dog behind
meg and Ryan has a dog as well named
Finn there are two dogs behind appear
like a Where's Waldo situation looked up
my dog yes there's a dog here too but
not in this room because he is very loud
shout outs to dogs
they're so cute you for having them here
today we're very happy that they are
here alright next question here we go
alright I just asked army bergna see we
got number eight the infamous story of
Benjamin Barker who sets up a barber
shop in London which is the base of her
painter suite on the Demon Barber of
Fleet Street correct that's portrayal is
horror alright good job to the chat for
guessing army of Darkness nice job
everyone there all right
number nine after her last encounter
Ellen Ripley crash lands on the Fiorina
ones that mad aliens
three oh no no no give to someone else I
strap Alien Resurrection no aliens alien
3 I start saying aliens that's why
number 10 a loan officer who makes an
old woman from her home finds herself
the recipient of a supernatural cause
curse this is desperate each Meg
drag me to hell correct yes
sam raimi baby yeah are you at 2:00 or
3:00 me yeah control-z right sorry
forgot control-z existed here we go a
simple man is turned into a genius
through the application of computer
science Matt Matt one more BAM correct
that is lawn mower guessing drag me to
hell good job and Jonathan got that also
right in the chat good job everyone
there uh spike Spiegel 26 and twitch got
lawnmower man good job good job
okay I could've sworn I saw it rented
from Blockbuster once and I just stopped
watching and went to my room and played
with Legos yeah that was a long time ago
anyway number 12 here we go here's a fun
one a vacationing family discovers that
the entire town they're visiting is
inhabited by goblins disguised as humans
who plan to eat them Matt Matt troll or
troll - which one correct
it is troll - is that really from the
90s holy cow yeah it is nilbog is God'll
installed backwards all right number 13
Laura Palmer's harrowing final days are
chronicled no I rock
correct all right
hey guys yes they got troll to you in
the chat I'm very proud of how many
people got you man no one should watch
that movie they're eating that they're
eating him
oh no I want to watch it it's terrible
it took me about 3 tries to actually get
through the whole thing um here we go
next question 14 a demonic force has
chosen Freddy Krueger as its portal to
the real world
later Haner Wes Craven's new nightmare
correct damn it's so good that synopsis
for troll 2 but yes word 7 8 9 did quote
they are gonna eat then they're gonna
eat me oh my god yes very proud of you
good you guys are doing great all right
just a reminder for everyone in the chat
we are taking donations for black lives
matter and fork over 19 relief efforts
there are links in the description below
I'm gonna pause really quick to check on
our donations for black lives matter and
for and mike has them open for kovetz I
hope you'll let us know when those come
in the most recent one we got was from
Harley Pettit for black lives matter it
was $25 thanks so much for that thank
you for that very much and if you guys
know doing it please do Ritchie's throw
in those links in the chat and the
donation links are also in the
description all right back to trivia
here we go a group of scientists try to
track down and trap a killer alien
seductress before she successfully mates
with a human beg brag splice peace right
now Ryan Ryan Ryan correct
one has Adrian Brody in it voucher
that's true but natasha Henstridge
really a newcomer to a Catholic Prep
high school falls in love with a trio of
outcasts teenagers who practice
witchcraft Matt the craft correct thanks
Chris all right 17 okay for young
friends bound by a tragic accident are
reunited when they find themselves being
stalked by a Ryan Ryan painter first
first hey I know what you did last
summer ex okay I'm an cook for hand good
job you guys in the chat are really good
a lot of them got species right very
nice words said crap movie all right and
spike Spiegel got species right and the
craft good job on the twitch chat here
we go next question three years ago
entomologists dr. susan tyler
genetically created an insect to kill
cockroaches carrying along with Ryan
relic very close what's the other one
that's exactly the same movie but not
know you get one everyone gets one guess
yeah so the whole in order for you to
guess the other panelists have to get
her John
they're gonna get it wrong now now the
insects yes
three three years ago and Tamala gist
dr. Susan Tyler genetically created and
set to kill cockroaches carrying a viral
disease now the insects are out to
destroy their only predator mankind no
Ryan again right I'm gonna let the chat
guess first is this the Gilmore de Toro
one I'm gonna let the chat guess first
yeah do you know what it is mmm-hmm
there's a delish I'm gonna give them a
few seconds before I let might be the
only one in the world that watched this
I've seen it I have seen this movie I
feel like these are getting more and
more obscure I am easing you into it
right was this the the Field Museum I
guess I got question 1 because it was a
softball I get it and no it is not
arachnophobia no it is not rats good
guesses though from the chat anyone else
have a guess
it is not phantoms they want to repeat
it ok I will repeat it one more time
here we go three years ago entomologist
dr. Susan Tyler Jeanette Lee created an
insect to kill cockroaches carrying a
viral it disease now the insects are out
to destroy their only predator mankind
it is not arachnophobia it is not a
bug's life ok
twitch got it gup-d in twitch gotta it's
mimicked spike Spiegel also got it Oh
Mira Sorvino right
yes Mira Sorvino correct all right the
chat has one for mimic good job to the
twitch chat for getting that right Joe's
apartment is incorrect that's a good
[Laughter]
b-movie also incorrect great movie
though all right here we go that was a
first stumper here we go ok I know
someone who's any other six complete
strangers with widely varying
personalities are involuntarily placed
at an endless maze containing deadly
traps yeah through Joe cube cube is so
good cube is so good to people because
hypercube sucks hypercube does hypercube
but then watch keep serious games watch
hypercube to please but honestly just
watch Q twice cube is so good so thank
you for getting that right
I love that movie alright last question
in synopsis a boy who communicates with
spirits seeks right
who was that I think it was him Miss
Hannah it was I think it was I think it
was Nina I mean it's the sixth sense I
think it was Hannah yeah yeah correct
all right I agree it was me all right so
at the end of round one we have a tie in
first for six points each Matt and Chris
are tied speaking of wrestle buddies why
don't you shout out wrestle buddies real
quick what is wrestle buddies go Matt
but Wilson buddies is a podcast on the
game spot podcasting Network thing that
we talk about wrestling and friendship
and fun things it's mostly us talking
about weird things in the 90s like
Robocop the and vampire warrior
professional wrestler Gangrel oh we love
Gangrel on the show all right good stuff
so that concludes round one Mike just
let me know if you see any donations on
the kovat side and I will check the BLM
side but you guys we are collecting
money and raising funds for black lives
matter and for Kovach 19 relief so let's
continue on to our next round those
donation links are in the description
below so please donate during the stream
so we are going on to do you want to
stay with horror and since you're kind
of in that mindset and do this name them
from the cast
it's do it I can't do math but I can
totally do this category four days all
right here we go all right 90s and
2000's [ __ ] name the movie from the
cast I will name three actors you're
free to chime in after one but just
please consider the fact they might be
in most of the horror films so please
don't shout out right after the first
one maybe wait for two all right number
one Gary Oldman when known a writer
Keanu Reeves Ryan Ryan Dracula
that is correct
all right here we go next question
Warwick Davis and Jennifer Aniston
painter rain leprechaun that is correct
it is leprechaun is my favorite category
here we go
you got this Morgan Freeman Brad Pitt
Gwyneth Paltrow Ryan Ryan 7 that is
correct Ryan's killing it this right I
studied all IMDB weekend guys twist Andy
must have really throw you for a loop
shout out to Red's to go to and now oz
forgetting leprechaun in the chat I'm
gonna check Pat twitch chat is doing
good job on getting Dracula spikes
people you're getting a lot of these
questions very proud of you all right on
to the next question
Chad Michael Murray Paris Hilton Jerrod
painter House of Wax
Paris Hilton's the key man yeah
remember when she also did music does
anyone remember this no way I think
she's a DJ no I would I would listen to
her DJing all right
Ritchie good job for writing 7 correctly
in the chat and Dustin good job on
getting House of Wax and Ritchie and now
us and Eduardo and Jonathan good job
trust me you'll get one of these next
one here he's back again Brad Pitt
Antonio Banderas Kirsten does Meg
alright Meg interview with vampire that
is correct
back in the board meg is back all right
here we go all right Adam Brody Amanda
Seyfried Megan Fox hey Meg
hey nur Jennifer's Body that is correct
meg how did you know was half a second
Richie's connect stars are blind is a
pop yes thank you for agreeing with me
all right good job on in the chat there
and spikes people said Paris Hilton made
a movie yeah people is correct
legitimate question though all right
here we go number seven George Clooney
Salma Hayek
Harvey kite that right from Dustin from
dusk till dawn correct good job reading
IMDB you did great next question
Jennifer Lopez Ice Cube Matt Matt yeah
Ice Cube yeah good job now was an Edward
up forgetting Jennifer's Body right I am
proud of you please watch that movie
hell is a teenage girl originated from
that movie really sounds like it's from
like a book or so it does it's not it's
from them I'm gonna caseinate a little
bit I'm not proud of all of you thank
you guys the donation links are in the
description below for black lives matter
and fork over nineteen direct relief
please help us out we're raising money
through this entire play for all events
we're going on for this is the fourth
week we're going on for a few more weeks
so please thank you for joining us for
our our charity streams and thanks for
donating all right anaconda is a
masterpiece is Hugo from Uruguay is not
wrong that is arts I stand by it
all right here we go Jada pinkett-smith
Timothy Olyphant
Courtney Cox
that Ryan Matt Nelson the Crypt demon
night no wait no Ryan Ryan was second
sorry Ryan Ryan a second it is screen
three
painter it is screen to - I got two
transfixed on Jada pinkett-smith I
apologize that's okay my man Timothy
Olaf an angel Grove said love this guy's
thank you thank you for tuning in thank
you arranged the Power Rangers the city
spike Spiegel said the cell I love Mike
do we have any donations yeah we we have
a Direct Relief donation from Harley
petty for $20 thank you so much Harley
to both causes thank you so much right
there stepping up here yeah thank you so
much yeah okay guys hold on we need to
shout out Nick Sherman from the GameSpot
team for donating two hundred dollars to
black lives thank you so much get that
match my bike um CBS immediately oh my
gosh thank you so much Nick you're great
be like Nick donate the donations our
links are in the comments below and also
Ritchie's dropping them in the chat all
right Dustin gia gia viñoly
Dustin do you have a nobody another one
of my friend yeah donated twenty
twenty-five dollars to black lives
matter thank you so much guys
incredible make us great friends awesome
Brandon said in the chat yeah go make
friends and Nick Sherman Nick you are a
hero thank you so much
alright here we go mmm where are we we
did scream to you
number 10 please don't go on the first
one because it could be more I might
event horizon correct
sandy all the next one no Samuels the
last one it was the obvious there's some
sci-fi horror mixed in here was a
transition the second one was gonna be
Joely Richardson but Sam you know was
the dead giveaway I was gonna say wow
like the best year ever
yeah I'm gonna say that's what scheana's
doing good job Spike's feel um he said
nice one Ryan okay here we go all right
next one Sigourney Weaver please don't
guess yeah Winona Ryder Ron Perlman and
offering elf ring that would be Alien
Resurrection that is Christmas new
resurrection wouldn't come up at some
point number twelve
Jordana Brewster fomka Jansen Elijah
Wood man L forgot
that's the faculty grinning would have
been the giveaway yeah I forgot the
pumpkin Jansen was in that movie 100%
her head was crawling around spoilers
it's a great watch it it's fantastic
faculty is the best move
I would like to shout out the people on
the shat screaming with faculty cuz they
know what's up because that movie is the
best that movie slaps alright thank you
there will probably be another faculty
question sometime oh yeah maybe will you
you might actually I appreciate your
dedication to your brand thank you right
Jared Leto Joshua Jackson and Tara Reid
painter oh no Jared Leto that is correct
almost saying final destination I was
like a timer the daily show guy was also
in the fact Lidia is correct Jon Stewart
was a teacher in he was part of the
faculty he was part of the faculty yeah
alright next one Liam Neeson Catherine
zeta-jones Owen Wilson meg Meg the
haunting that is correct I love it
alright Thomas Jane Sam Jackson LL Cool
J Ryan Ryan with oh my god do me proud
uh-huh you're saying it deep deep blue
sea that's right what's the song from
that Sam Jack blue is my hat is like a
shark's fin good job guys
all right Eduardo said the haunting he
got that right good job proud of you
spike Spiegel said Jared Leto was an
urban legend yes he was all right
Michelle Williams not from Destiny's
Child HT
oh my god it's just killing it with the
slashers over here
and that brings us to the end of the
horror segment so very good job let's
take a look at these scores so Chris
Hanna is leading with 12 points in
second Matt elfin with 9 Ryan Peterson
came up in this round with seven and
then we've got Meg with four and Mike
with three and chat with one all right
so guys we are raising money for black
lives matter and Cova 19 relief please
please donate we've got those links in
the description and registering them and
chat as well and thank you so much for
hanging out with us today we're doing
trivia for another hour and a half and
I've got more categories so the next
thing we're doing meg great news it's
superhero comic book time it's gonna be
the most embarrassing moment of my life
but bear in mind it's 90s and 2000 so
there there's not a lot of MCU in here
just so you know we're gonna start with
synopsis donation real quick
oh Mack I'm Mike but my name is Mike
Jones ready for it $69 69
[Laughter]
my heart Ronald Jones also donated to
black lives matter with $25 Shawn
Wozniak with $25 the black lives matter
and I love this thank you alright so
we're on to the next category which is
superhero comic movies from the 90's and
2000's you guys want to do synopsis
first let's do synopsis here we go all
right some of these are very flexible
with the term superheroes
that's just think about it a half
vampire half mortal man Jojo late that
is correct
Mike's back i ISIL I'm salon over 6969
thank you so much all right a giant egg
is unearthed at a construction site and
soon opens releasing the terrible Ivan
ooze painter yeah my god of course its
Mighty Morphin Power Rangers the movie
that is correct
it is Mighty Morphin Power Rangers of
the movie all right that was you angel
Grove love you angel Grove all right in
a world where evolved super-powered
humans exist and are discriminated
against Jojo x-men that is correct it is
the first x-men that's a wild
description I want to shout out some
people getting them right in chat words
seven eight nine got blade eduardo got
blade words already guess that let's see
Power Rangers was guessed correctly by
Ren and Dustin thank you so much for
that donation earlier and yet Mighty
Morphin Power is yes thanks for shouting
out Mike we got any donations yeah we
got a couple more we got SWA's donated
$25 and with an exclamation mark so
hopefully now why's all donated $10
thank you so much to us oh also Noah's
donated to black lives matter $10 a year
is you are amazing
thank you guys so much for being here if
you can't donate that's totally fun to
share the links and thanks for hanging
out with us thanks for supporting we
really appreciate it
all right back to the questions in a way
I did that one number four a brilliant
scientist left for dead returns to exact
revenge on the people who burned him
alive
Matt Matt dark man that is dark man
corrects what he deserves that he got it
right it's almost a horror movie so
that's why it's gonna say it's it's
flexible this round here we go
and also horror had so many I had made
so many horror movie isn't they done did
not make a lot of superhero ones here we
go a supernatural Exorcist and
demonologist helps a policewoman prove
her sister's death was not a suicide but
something more Haner
Constantine that is correct Oh God
that's a wild description of that movie
- I like that movie it is not as good as
the TV show
agreed all right next one an elite
mercenary is killed but comes back from
Hell as a reluctant soldier right Matt
right spawn what that is correct it's
kind of horror still the mythical world
starts a rebellion against humanity in
order to rule the earth so he and his
team must save the world from Elias
creatures Matt Hellboy - the Golden Army
that is correct thank you for staying
the flow titles thank you Wow okay ooh
all right
the chat is getting a lot of these angel
groves got Constantine Nawaz got
Constantine good job spawn was got yeah
ran words Gillison Eduardo Richie and
Nawaz all got spawn proud of y'all did
ain't your Grove get the Power Rangers
movie that's what I wanted I missed the
chat okay the chats moving too I'm
assuming I resumed yes all right here we
go next question for superheroes a
strange black entity from another world
bonds with him and causes inner turmoil
as he contends with the creators painter
spider-man 3 that is correct it is
spider-man 3
ramie movies like legit there was a
minute I was like what the world now
aware of his identity he must contend
with both his declining health and a
vengeful madman he's described is this
Oh The Dark Knight Rises
I guess you say it again with the world
now aware of his identity he must
contend with both his declining health
and a vengeful madman uh Meg Meg iron
man 2 correct ha before 2010 wow that's
a wild decision that movie that is a
wild description doesn't sound anything
like it I was like what Superman she was
a 2010 movie
Cassidy frantically googling I don't
know what year I came out yeah here we
go
life in time is a blur good job to
everyone in the chat I got it right
Dustin Jonathan Manny I was thinking
like I was firmly in like ok don't say
any MCU movies I've been a fool and Lord
luck and a spike Spiegel also got it
right own twitch chat alright here we go
I'm moving on from Iron Man 2 in an
alternate Victorian age world a group of
famous contemporary fantasy science Matt
elf ring the League of Extraordinary
Gentlemen that is correct
good job offering my name is one
syllable long and this is somehow just
so hard for me to get out quickly
every time is the hardest part buzzing
it is the tough part guys we're
collecting donations still so those
donation links are in the description
and Ritchie's throwing them in chat so
thanks to those thank you to everyone
who donated so far here we go not a
direct relief donation from just
Giovanelli $25 thank you so much Dustin
thank you
you the best all right here we go an
undercover FBI agent becomes a vigilante
assassin and sets out to unleash his
wrath upon the corrupt businessman who
slaughtered his entire entire family at
a reunion Dana Haines er Punisher that
is correct
2004 s Punisher I was like I don't
remember him being an FBI agent neither
do I see my tweet from last week about
the description for the matrix on
Netflix it's like the most ridic
it was a simple life and it's like jeez
is like Ritchie and Harley and Noah's
all got it right they all got Punisher
and Hugo in Eduardo very nice good job
getting Punisher here we go numero 12 a
frustrated office worker learns that he
is the son of a profession professional
assassin and that he shares his father's
superhuman killing abilities that's what
we're trying to figure out right yeah
let's see the chance at first yeah I'll
wait for y'all but let's get the check
mm-hmm a frustrated office worker learns
that he is the son of a professional
assassin and that he shares his father's
superhuman abilities I know this one but
I can't it's wanted Matt that is correct
it is wanted curve the bullet you just
got it Dustin just got it as well good
job I'm also giving that to chat because
you basically answered at the same time
because of the 10-second delay so check
it yeah and Madeline Matt you also get
the point because all right good job
good job all right check it Stu
here we go
all right an unnoticed high school
student and comic book fan one day
decides to become a superhero
I feel like I'm gonna get it wrong now
spider-man but I don't think that's
right
nope kick-ass that's correct
prematurely yelling my name at the same
time like an idiot dollar just Pokemon
today it's fine also for the chat if you
tuned in late and didn't hear this if
the chat gets the point I will donate to
both causes and I will have it matched
by mic on CBS so thank you for chiming
in and getting those points and really
proud of y'all alright here we go the
last question in the synopsis category
for superheroes because there weren't
that many movies alright rookie cop
Denny Colt returns from beyond as a hero
whose mission is to fight against the
bad forces in Central City wait the year
is 2008 I will give that as a clue
because this is I pulled out of nowhere
wait can you read it one more time Matt
Matt RIPD no that was gonna be my guess
I'm glad you did it not me I'll read it
one more time and I'll wait for the chat
to answer as well rookie cop
Denny Colt returns from the beyond as a
hero whose mission is to fight against
the bad forces in Central City
I mean Central's I mean central city but
it's not that it's no that's why this
one is the last question cuz it's super
sucks
Rajjo Inspector Gadget incorrect
I shall Bob Jones 1980 got it the check
at the point it is the spirit soaring
Gabriel mocked and Scarlett Johansson
has just a twitch chat
Spike's pika Bob Jones Congrats you got
that point you're representing the chat
and I'm donating to charity all right
that is it for the superhero round we
are moving on to the next category 90s
and 2000's action movies and before I do
I'm going to remind you all that we are
raising money for black lives matter and
for koban 19 relief through direct
belief so those links for donating are
in the description below so please help
us out and thank you to everyone that's
donated so far I still can't get over
6969 so thank you really attached my
heart today all right on to 90's and
2000's action movies Ryan you're gonna
be back you're back for this I know
you're in for this you've got that zero
points last round so yeah I got it I got
it
action movies here we go alright oh wait
do we do cast yet no oh alright
nevermind let's go back to superhero I
forgot I just went to sorry Ryan was
good at this last round here we go I've
got 18 questions with superhero comic
book cast so named the movie from the
cast Danny DeVito Michelle Pfeiffer
hater
Batman Returns that is correct best
Batman movie debatable Batman and Robin
is a heck of a lot of fun that's not
true but it's a heck of a lot of fun
here we go james marsden don't answer
right away Rebecca Romijn Brian Cox
Matt Matt oh you said don't answer right
away but x-men which x2 okay that is
correct that is correct
knighted yeah x2 x-men United because I
said Brian Cox mmm-hmm all right here we
go
val kilmer anyone hater hater Batman
Forever that is correct
I was gonna keep reading but I feel like
someone already knew okay next one
Sylvester Stallone Donald Lane right
I'll Frank
I jumped in too quick but Judge Dredd
that is correct who I was again I know
you thought it was gonna be
there's another one that I'm waiting for
here here we go I remembered the
category okay
JK Simmons James Franco Alberto yeah
Matt painter spider-man which one oh man
three no to Maggie were second I sweat
him in two
that is correct Alfred Molina baby baby
man he was so great in that movie so
good can we give him an award just just
like a retro action thanks for game spot
make an award and Janet Alfred Molina
cuz we should study should commission a
trophy I think we should you're the best
thank you for your work 15 years old but
that's it on fire everyone is getting
Judge Dredd and spider-man to you I'm
proud of all of you losing their minds
over Alfred Molina all the Molina heads
number six Billy Zane Catherine
zeta-jones eyes mat the Phantom that is
correct
good god this is my wheelhouse man I was
a teenager
yeah Ryan Reynolds we have Shriver Ryan
Ryan yes that's correct
everybody should get a point except
right yeah Ryan you are awarded no
points
that's great okay where's the where's
the 90s Adam Sandler um I'll just quote
the entirety of all right here we go
next question I forgot where I want us
here we go
Aaron Eckhart Maggie Gyllenhaal manic
hater
Matt I'm sorry Meg I'll stop talking
mute yourself here we go
Shaquille O'Neal Oh
deal that is correct it is Seattle I
know my Shaq boo hey Matt name the other
one then uncle George Lucas am Kazaam
children also oh all right shout out to
the people in chat that got looting
rights like Johnny is good and people in
the twitch channel so got it as well
here we go all rights next up we have
Terrence Howard Jeff Bridges mag Iron
Man that is correct
oh yeah here we go ben stiller william h
Macy and know that all star by
smashmouth was first on that soundtrack
before sure I totally did yeah I love
that song that's a good karaoke song BBQ
preferred salt and pepper at the shoe
peasant Mercurio shoe is a good song
Shoop is also a good song all right here
we go
um Colin Farrell Michael Clarke Duncan
Jennifer Garner
Ryan oh dang it beard I think that is
correct it is daredevil John Farrell
with a bull's-eye
at least we forget yeah okay next up
Jennifer Connelly Nick Nolte Eric Bana
hey right hey nur oh that is correct
he's just called Hulk the title is just
I don't remember much about dogs in it
oh boy all right after Hulk
we have Naomi Watts iced tea Noorie
petit right Matt Ryan Tank Girl that is
corrected his tanker nice good job okay
Kelsey Grammer Vinnie Jones Tanner x-men
3 The Last Stand that is correct
[Laughter]
Sharon Stone Benjamin Bratt Halle Berry
painter painter Catwoman that is correct
Catwoman for likening venom to cow that
is a very appropriate comparison at
least we forget the basketball scene in
that film yeah a great scene like that
whole movie and that's that one scene
gets like undo hey chad is blowing up
cuz they know Catwoman one two three
four five six seven people in a row back
Catwoman right my people shoutouts to
them by the way we are also collecting
money and raising it for donating to
black lives matter and copa90 and Direct
Relief those links are in the
description Richie's been throwing them
in the chat thank you guys so much for
donating please help us out as we are
raising money you guys are doing great
all right we have two more questions in
this category
Ava Mendez
wes Bentley Ghost Rider Ghost [ __ ] what
year did Ghost Rider come out I was
trained in July 2007
that is correct fully mobile was that
you hater yeah
oh my god why did my point that was
Vegas
uh all right here we go
Liv Tyler Tim Roth William Hurt painter
painter The Incredible Hulk that is
correct it is oh my god
whoa all right good job that is the end
of that round Chris Haner has 24 points
what's a matter what a surprise that's
coming up before you with 21 and then
we've got Ryan with 9 Meg with 7 and
Mike with 5 he does not say mine yeah I
can read the top 5 thank you guys for
your donations thank you for tuning in
we still have more trivia all the way to
2 p.m. Pacific time we're moving on
action movies here we go
all right you can do some of these I
guess you all right here's the synopsis
for number 1 humans in a fascist
militaristic future wage Raider painter
oh now you can't answer for this round
unless nobody else answers it's humans
and a fascist militaristic future wage
war with giant alien bugs Ryan Ryan
Starship Troopers
Ryan love starships could be like
[Laughter]
demolition man I wanted to get the one I
heard humans and future
so man I want to shout out to Eduardo
Ritchie and Hugo who all got 2007 right
in the very proud of you for calling out
the exact year that that movie came out
that's very impressive here we go as
Earth is invaded by alien tripod
fighting machines one family fights for
survival rights War of the Worlds that
is correct
all right each year three brothers visit
their grandfather for the summer he's
highly skilled in ninjutsu and for years
he's trained boys man no he said three
ninja turtles but that's no gainer
is it three ninjas that is correct it is
[Laughter]
there's three of those movies I don't
know if you know they're totally high
noon at mega mountain and shout outs of
people have Scott starships who are
saying Starship Troopers
Dustin Ren Nawaz Eduardo yeah good job
all all right here we go after three
ninjas here we go number four Sam
Witwicky leaves the Autobots behind Matt
Gaynor transformers is it revenge of the
Fallen that is correct I was looking for
the exact title and you got it
it is revenge of the Fallen dumbest name
wiki what a name alright John McClane
and a Harlem Stone story later that was
Ryan hmm that is die hard with a
vengeance that is correct
good job the best one of the series I've
never seen a guy that's trying to say
that number one is great but I brought
that right now go watch die hard one
after this in the chat eduardo thank you
for getting the full name Transformers
Revenge of the Fallen if you
you know you're not wrong mister all
right here we go a retired master car
thief must come back to the gone in sick
on in 60 seconds that is correct
maybe in order to foil a terrorist plot
an F painter write painter that's face
off that is correct
[Laughter]
oh my god
the theme is over all right a man ready
a man is picked up by a fishing boat
bullet riddled and suffering from
amnesia before racing to elude assassins
and attempting to regain his memory
sounds like every JRPG ever wanted what
Brian is it assassins no Matt Matt
identity that is corrected as well
you're not missing much
great I'm going to wait for the delay on
the chat and see if they got it or not
okay here we go
all rights next question with the help
of a magic ticket a young movie veteran
Matt Last Action Hero
that is correct I beat you I beat fun
fact the kid from Last Action Hero lived
on my floor in the dorm freshman year of
college
oh wow random nice I'm going to give the
chat another point the chats gonna get
now the chat has four points is it three
or four I think it's I'm just gonna get
14 the chat has four points now because
they got the Bourne Identity thank you
thank you for chiming in good job chat
alright a shout out to mr. t-bone SF and
man limit or forgetting Bourne Identity
all right here we go next question what
I just asked last action hero here
an extreme sports athlete is Matt the
blacks that's correct yes lacks a last
action here was in the 90s not the
eighties yeah thank you for asking
alright here we go and it was 1993 all
right a loyal and dedicated Hong Kong's
inspector teams up with a reckless and
handling caner rush hour that is correct
like for a bonus point what year did
that movie come out 2003 1998 that is
correct
[Laughter]
wild all right number 12 former a former
cop is called upon to bust a dangerous
criminal and Matt demolition man so
close let me keep reading the former cop
is called upon to bust a dangerous
criminal and he recruits the help of a
former childhood friend and street racer
who has a chance to redeem himself
Rajjo knows wrong fast and furious that
is incorrect but you're very close
street racer Trixie Trixie chastity hmm
you're very close though can you say it
one more time a former cop is called
upon to bust a dangerous criminal and he
recruits the help of a former friend
Haner
is it too fast to fear that is corrected
I love that movie they're all my
favorite one
alright I'll see if the chat I'll wait
for the lag and see if the chat also got
it and I will give them a point if so
yes they did vivec got too fast too
furious correct so the chat is back on
the board with five points now get it
chat good job chat Ritchie also got it
okay here we go a computer hacker breaks
into the computer system of the Seabourn
legend cruiseliner
and sets its pants Packers No
my inner Ryan's the net no no hater
hater speed to cruise control oil
frigate I heard both the hacker how
excited I couldn't wait to say speech
Ritchie thank you for dropping those
donation links in the chat we are
collecting donations for black lives
matter and Cove in nineteen relief so
thank you to everyone who has donated so
far all right we're gonna keep going
with these action-movie synopses okay a
board married couple is surprised to
learn that they are both assassins right
painer
sure mrs. who was it I think it was mrs.
Smith that is correct and I would let it
slide but like I really need some points
[Laughter]
alright good job Mike
thank you alright an American agent
under false suspicion of disloyalty must
discover and expose the real spy without
the help of his organization Ryan er
Ryan enemy of the state
incorrect Haner mission impossible
correct definitely hoping she chose the
first one all right
professional assassin learns his rival
has injected him with a poison that will
kill him if his heart next painter you
are you next its is it crank that is
correct it is crank good job because
maybe the best idea for a movie
[Laughter]
it is nuts it is kind of fun it's trash
but it's it's fun watch Craig - Craig -
ring - high voltage high voltage is
insane but also problematic thank you
it's me but Jason Statham is the bus
yeah that's a really should that should
be the synopsis for the movie anyway
next alright next time we do this we do
I write the synopses so for the title
the title pops up in the synopses I'm
going to read it as blank all right here
we go years after a friend and fellow
agent is killed on a joint mission a
secret space-based weapons program
called blank is stolen
Joe Rochelle its Goldeneye but yeah it
is do you Mike hey run my game oh all
right a gun for hire known only as blank
hired by a group known as the
organization is ensnared and a political
conspiracy which rhymes him first Ryan
hitman that is correct it is hitman
Stern your boy Timothy Olyphant
a data courier literally carrying a data
package inside his head man no no I
gotta stop saying things too early who
said no is that Haner that was me who's
next
yeah all right a data courier literally
carrying a data package inside his head
must deliver it before he dies from the
burden or is killed by the Yakuza I mean
I'll give it to the chat I'm gonna give
them 10 seconds to guess does anyone
know this one a data curse I know what
it is by recently carrying a data
package inside his head must deliver it
before he dies from the burden or is
killed by the officer correct vivec got
it right with Johnny mnemonic yeah
[Music]
six points all right it's a good job to
chat here we go
all right think a little bit outside the
box here when a teenager she witnesses
the kidnapping of her father by wealthy
crime lord blank when she grows up she
goes into a quest for vengeance and
becomes a famous crime fighter or street
fight
one might say hater inner street fighter
The Legend of chun-li that is correct
good job there was a chun-li movie there
were Kristin Kreuk Kristin Smallville
and the dude who the dude from American
Pie who's not any of the ones you
remember correct Chris Klein did
American Pie and then he did this movie
and he was also known I think for dating
Katie yeah all right
cool here we go we're us also still
collecting donations so if you guys want
to throw in even a dollar or two there's
no donation to small we've got donation
links in the box below the description
also in the chat thank you
all right here we go an interstellar
teleportation device found in Egypt that
Stargate is correct Matt it is Stargate
trying to stop screaming out my name and
just going no I don't know here we go
all right next one an FBI agent goes
undercover to catch a gang of surfers
[Music]
[Laughter]
Ryan your dad worked on that movie right
yeah my dad did props for that movie no
literally if anyone deserves its mic
though I'm happy that Mike got it it is
I would say a perfect film yeah yes
never see 70 grand also got it right
good job and so don't know Wallis and
Ron Jones Jonathon proud of you guys all
right after Point Break here we go when
a man goes for a virtual vacation
memories of the planet Mars and
unexpected I'm very bad at trivia I get
very angry at myself okay um
next one dr. Richard Kimble anyone Ryan
Ryan the fugitive that is correct
proud of you all right here's the last
one
three unknowing martial artists are
summoned to a mysterious island to
compete in a tournament Ryan Ryan portal
combat that is correct it is moral Conda
thank you so much
all right that concludes the synopses
portion of this round just reminder
we're having a green banners look at his
little legs twitching he's dreaming that
I'm doing better
[Laughter]
here's the top three scores again Chris
with 34 Matt with 27 Ryan with 15 that's
the top three and you combine my and Meg
score if you had a fight as a unit I
will allow it does I mean the thing is
Mike and I both have incredibly nice
knowledge things that are not included
I guess it's time to spread your wings
here we go
90s and 2000's action movies name from
the cast okay number one Rachel Vice
Arnold Vosloo Brendan Fraser we jump
bridge Oh The Mummy
that's right that was for you guys I
know you love that I didn't wanna I had
it at Rachel Weisz I didn't want to say
prematurely though all right here we go
Kate Beckinsale Hugh Jackman Robbie
Coltrane oh hey no hey nur van Helsing
van Helsing is correct all right next
one Tommy Lee Jones Vincent D'Onofrio
Joe Rochelle man in black that is
correct
proud of you like with the double digits
night oh my god no I yes all right
i rescind my offer a lot of movie fans
in the chat proud of you all good job
that's that's a great movie great here
we go Jordana Brewster ja Rule Michelle
Rodriguez yeah Rajjo is that fast and
furious that is correct it is the first
fast and furious rule wasn't that yeah
that was the key to that question here
we go
Hilary Swank Pat Morita Goggins Haner
the next Karate Kid that is correct
proud of you I rented that on VHS a
couple of noggins I forgot what God gets
is in there so did I what a cream what a
career indeed all right Bill Murray Sam
Rockwell drew Barrymore oh my god that's
a weird cast yeah
Sam Rockwell's and Bill Murray uh-huh
this is 100% that movie that was just
seen on video tape over and over again
necessarily I just didn't name the
obvious ones because it is hmm if I name
the core cast Angel groves got it right
the check gets it right before you guys
it is Charlie's Angels and the check
it's Angel groves got it for the check
good job so proud of you so did spike
Spiegel on the twitch chat also got try
this and dissection also got it nice job
getting it all right ed Harris Nicolas
Cage Sean Connery painter painter
the rock that is correct or as we know
him Dwayne Johnson feel like that
follow-up should disqualify you from
that Mike have you seen I'm well aware
of the film it has nothing to do a
Johnson house shadow no probably
forgetting trans Angeles I liked that
movie all right um
they're celebrating their success like
oh my god [ __ ] love you chat yeah we
love you too next one Mark Wahlberg
Helena Bonham Carter Michael Clarke
Duncan
I feel like I should know that watching
Chris's face sorry
[Laughter]
Mark Wahlberg naanum carpet Carter and
Michael Clarke Duncan this is a hard one
I don't think I saw this in theory I
don't know
while we are pausing please donate to
black lives matter and Co V 19 relief
we've got those links in the description
below and thank you to everyone that's
donated so far and thank you guys for
hanging out with us during our trivia
we're having a great time here with all
of you and you guys are doing great
you're getting lots of points except for
me I feel like this is a video game
adaptation
I remember Mark Wahlberg being in a
video game adaptation that I did not see
inky Joe gets to Boogie Nights that is
incorrect that is an action is it you
know it is not shooter no does not Max
Payne thank you for guessing
does anyone know what it is no all right
the answer I'm just gonna wait for chat
for one more second and see if anyone
gets it otherwise no this is the first
question that no one has gotten tell no
one here can tell if you're cheating in
chat so okay I'm gonna say it alright
they have five seconds five four three
yep Roger Jesse got it Planet of the
Apes
[Laughter]
okay Hugo from your way also just got it
good job proud of you okay that was the
first number alright Jamie Lee Curtis
Tom Arnold oh hey Ryan Ryan Ryan True
Lies that is correct
Chris cheats again I heard Ryan Chris is
your volume up louder something I heard
Chris first yeah yeah
I'm on this it's okay I tried something
on one earlier and it didn't go through
at all
so okay where she said no way we don't
cheat
we trust you okay everyone is admirably
playing with their own knowledge I'm
just saying you can choose you have no
way to tell that's that's true we have
no way to tell and it's for charity
yeah the more points that Chet gets the
more I donate all right here we go next
one Topher Grace Adrian Brody
Laurence Fishburne oh my god her grace
was in movies that weren't spider-man 3
yeah Ryan right predators that is
correct
thank you for giving me actually a good
predator movie that movie and I stopped
because I thought it was after 2010
noise from Chad is also getting a point
he's a guest at the same time because of
the delay a twitch chat gutter right
spike Spiegel and Genki Joe and
dissection all that predators correct
and lordly danny trejo movie good job
and also they are getting it in the
YouTube chat now as well because I think
twitch chat is slightly faster up Hugo
Noah's wrong
Dustin Roger all of you Eduardo Quinn
good job guessing predators okay here we
go I just said predators here Denise
Richards Judi Dench Pierce Brosnan jo3
Jam is it the world is not enough that
is correct it was way up I wasn't saying
wild things yeah what a twist
yeah Michelle Yao chow yun-fat
Zhang Ziyi
Matt Matt I've seen House of Flying
Daggers incorrect meg Meg Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon correct Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon so good right
gary oldman Glenn Close Harrison Ford
Glenn Close mm-hmm Gary Oldman Glenn
Close Harrison Ford
I feel like I can see the boxart I'm so
I'm gonna wait for the chat today let's
see if the track gets it Oh yep chat got
it dissection got it
Air Force one gets the point shot has
ten points good job y'all
can I team up with chat me and chat just
like let's do this because then I'll be
in last place again shout out to Richie
who guessed 101 dalmatians and also
shout out to Richie because he donated
thank you so much Richie recommend a for
$25 to black lives matter thank you if
you want to be cool like Richie those
donation links are in the description
below for black lives matter and for
Copa 19 relief so thank you guys
alright next one after Air Force One Ed
Norton
Mark Wahlberg Charlize Theron Tanner
Haner
the Italian Job corrects the Italian Job
it made me want a mini cooper also Seth
Green pretending to invent master
remember Napster yeah dude I mean no I
never used it I know friends who used it
anyway next Helen Hunt Bill Paxton
painter Reiner right that's twister
that's correct
it is hater has rights
all right like every other person on who
seems like Chrissy's gonna win good job
to vivec Eduardo and Jonathan you got
Italian job correct and also spikes Pico
got that as well
proud of you all right next one Diane
Kruger
Sean Bean Nicolas Cage painter painter
national treasure
nailed it is national treasure I was
like okay gently alia DMM egg man damned
right Oakland gently was not in Queen of
the Damned pariahs cradle to the grave
no Aliyah and DMX were in cradle it was
not I know gently and DMX were in cradle
agree but Elia was not really yes why
which movie was alia and that wasn't
Queen of the Damned I think actually now
I'm second-guessing myself but kiss of
the Dragon no damn thank you for
guessing let's see the chat gets it
it's a Leo but the check got it twitch
chat got it right spike Spiegel and
Genki Jo and dissection and kid karma
got it Romeo Must Die is the answer how
many people in the chat no more than oh
yeah good job um thank you to the chat
yes it was Romeo Must Die gently alia
DMX that was a tricky one because yes
cradle-to-grave was an alternate answer
but one of those actors was not gonna
okay Matthew McConaughey Penelope Cruz
Steve Zahn Ryan McConaughey Cruz Steve
Zahn Steve Zahn Vicki who else who else
anyone nobody lives on being the key
into an action movie cuz he's on the
poster
yep the section got in the twitch chat
it is Sahara
mm-hmm 2005 good job so the chat gets
another point that is 12 points for the
chats thank you so much for helping us
out because I will be donating for each
dollar for each point I will donate $1
and have it matched all right here we go
fools gold is a good guess that that is
not mm all right next one
this one is tricky Channing Tatum Marlon
Wayans Dennis Quaid Oh painter painter
GI Joe what is the full name of the
movie but I'm probably gonna give it to
you is it [ __ ] is it GI oh no because I
don't think come on is it just yeah Joe
The Rise of Cobra yep that is correct oh
really good job all right last one here
in this category my girl ming-na wen
jean-claude van Damme Kylie Minogue
painter caner that's Street Fighter the
man that is Street Fighter than love it
all right that was it for the action
movies so we are moving on to the
lightning rounds today are you available
we're gonna be doing movie posters next
yep alright so for movie posters I have
saved 30 movie posters onto my desktop
and then zoomed in on a portion of the
poster you have to call out your name if
you recognize it first
it is a lightning round so we'll
probably go pretty fast as a reminder
before we do this we are connec
collecting donations for black lives
matter and Cova 19 relief through direct
relief so thank you to everyone that
donated and if you would like to donate
no donation is too small please use the
links in the description below alright
thank you guys so much I feel like if
you are a more visual person you will do
well in this round
hey are you ready
I'll just yeah I'll say next yeah mmm
here we go
also Chris should blindfold himself the
whole time first dibs on all of these so
I can redeem myself a little bit for the
questions I had so much fun putting this
together on Friday morning I am here to
take no prisoners Wow yes go for it
are you ready man you know Matt Shiel
bill that is correct it is Kill Bill
reveal it's ready for the next one like
you all sit at the same time rougeau
independence a huh independence a yep
correct
Maggie you got a double click on the yep
got it got it yeah there are two windows
and zoom one will show you everything
yep show the full screen don't poster so
Mike got one okay yay ready for the next
one
Nader Meg van helsing incorrect hey nerd
painter Batman Begins correct
what this is my lightning Arnaz getting
all of these wrongs next Manor Meg
sounds little imps correct
got that one that's fine thank you
mm-hmm Ryan painter Ryan Man of Steel
incorrect hey nur hanis Superman Returns
correct Superman oh my god yes 2006 holy
crap hmm
painter painter Cloverfield correct it
is Cloverfield
Wow killing it is a plan of Ames again
so I'll guess next Ryan let's see if the
check Ryan the faculty that's a good
guess it's not the little house in the
corner Sarah me off yeah I don't
recognize all right I'm gonna see the
check at sit let's see if the check at
sit it's the what's his name anyone else
guesses Shia one huh anyone else got
guesses let's see I'm gonna wait for
this no i-section guest butterfly effect
that is incorrect
yep Ritchie got it in the chat so chat
got it it's Donny Darko how incredible
guests thank you good job Richie Rich is
just yelling Donny Darko beautiful all
right next
Ryan office space
correct
classic show it all right next one Matt
beg Matt wait how'd American summer
correct that was for you oh boy all
right nice work Richie okay next one a
Turner that is the mask correct
I was look at that horrifying image look
at it okay next one
Oh hater hater Buffy the Vampire Slayer
correct Buffy the Vampire Slayer also a
Joss Whedon the movie came out in 92
before the show did also never seen the
show he surprises me Meg yeah I tried it
Richie said that cleft for about the
mask and a lot of people guessed it
right Dustin and wardo Rinna was
Jonathan Quinn good job track not enough
people said trick not enough Shrek
guesses all right next one
we know who Joe is that lost in
translation that is correct that is lost
in translation whoa oh yeah good job
great on to the next
meg Meg Hellboy that is yes the first
Hellboy yes a Golden Army had no more
into everything
good job Meg all right number 14 hey hey
nur that's scream of course it is yeah
it is scream okay next writer Ryan oh my
god the super super second
it's Hancock Will Smith the drunken
superhero Ryan don't pull a mat okay
next meg Ryan Meg Candyman correct that
is Candyman for a bonus point meg what
year did that come out oh my god this is
miserable for me 1993 uh-uh no you're
all wrong yes one out of ten is 96 nope
three maybe I should check what year is
it
oh wait for the delay and then I'll
probably give them a point on to the
next one or 90 to 91 hey it was 92 Haner
that is The Nightmare Before Christmas
correct all right all right uh the point
goes to Ritchie who guessed it right
with the delay for 1992 so checking
other points 14 points I'm pretty sure
yep 14 points let's see Chris you have
51 points that is wild
this is wild guys we are still raising
money for charity here with this dream
so please donate to black lives matter
or to Cove a nineteen relief or both
those links are in the description below
and throwing them in chat thank you to
everyone who's been donating during this
stream I have a couple of donations here
so I'm gonna read these out so puzzle or
hazel Mohammed $20 to black lives matter
thank you so much and then Roger Jesse
$25 to black lives matter
thank you so much for your donation
thank you all right back to the posters
spider-man
that is correct that was Meg sorry which
yes correct yourself that's true
bye bye don't say the answer is don't
guess guess also there in front of you
[Laughter]
he's not looking at me yeah that's what
they all say
oh boy how is that Oh Meg magner
underworld incorrect hey nerd I totally
forgot what I'm thinking of Matt Pan's
Labyrinth correct Matt not what I was
thinking I get Matt's got 30 points now
only 800 behind Chris yeah rob has
joined the chat he guessed clairewych
good job hi alright uh next one please
this may be an alternate poster Matt Big
Lebowski
yes that is correct
on to the next a neuron tanner
that's the 40 year old virgin mm-hmm
look at Steve Carell he looks like a
baby you know that's such a good poster
like look at that poster I think one day
to make space anyway moving on next
writer Ryan hold fiction correct Ryan
with 19 points now next tricky one
Ryan Ryan requiem for a dream Wow Wow
Ryan Wow good job points Ryan we're
getting rekt man with a dream all right
here we go next one
Matt Matt Kevin fever yes cabins all
right all right
like Ryan
cable guy corrects Ryan's coming back up
next meg Meg watchman correct it is
watchman median baby nice nice it is the
comedian meg Meg Rocketeer correct that
is bracha to you I'm coming back Mike
and Meg are tied and chat Mike Megan
chatter tied right who got it I I was I
think right right Brian
Titanic correct Ryan Ryan the faculty
that is correct
[Laughter]
Thank You chastity you're welcome thank
you for guessing of course it's there it
was gonna come back eventually
that is a movie that you should watch
it's it's a great film is aliens yeah
yeah great good time Wow I'll go one
further it's the movie about aliens oh
yeah okay it's C Mars Attacks Krita like
that alright um so we are collecting
donations to black lives matter and to
Cova 19 relief so those links are in the
description below and thank you to
everyone who has donated we have about
20 minutes left in the stream give or
take and we are moving on to our next
lightning round which is movie taglines
so these cover all genres between 1990
and 2010 so it could be anything so
you're not being helped by the genre
anymore so bear that in mind
are you ready because their tag lines
not synopses but some of them are
written like synopses so that might help
you out some of them are super not all
right here we go number one there are
three point seven trillion fish in the
ocean they're looking for one mat mat
Finding Nemo correct Finding Nemo I got
in a kid I got a one-up on you welcome
to the Pixar around an ordinary place an
extraordinary thriller the terrible
tagline an ordinary place an
extraordinary thriller this is a 90s
movie I don't know oh it's not thank you
for guessing
I tried welcome I will see if the chat
gets it right
they also guessed Pleasantville that's
not lunch at we're in this together an
ordinary place and extraordinary
thriller all right um this movie was
turned into a TV series man I guess
that's the bone collector incorrect
Oh Joe the burbs a year ago Z trooper X
and the YouTube chat got it right with
Fargo the 15 points for Chad no no
describe that movie first yeah
tag lines are tough that's why I save
this for last
all right here we go his story will
touch you even though he can't Rochelle
Rochelle Bob oh boy that's a good guess
it's not correct his story will touch
you even though he can't
around Hannah we got Fargo right good
job oh nice so did an view Matt a I know
that's a great guess yes I like that
guess Oh Ryan Ryan Ryan Ryan a Green
Mile the green now agreement hmm
incorrect
why can't he could powder he can't touch
you kiss he has to stay inside out of
the Sun oh boy no one's getting it in
chat either it's not Casper thank you
for guessing that all right Genki Joe
got it in the twitch chat it is Edward
Scissorhands touch you you just get
stabbed
Madol mature also got it in the YouTube
chats a good job there all right 16
points for chat next one after a night
they can't remember comes a day they'll
never forget
later Joe dude where's my car yeah just
because they serve you doesn't mean
argue Haner that it waiting that's a
good guess no right oh no Ryan yep what
it is that is the tagline yeah all right
next one is welcome to earth population
1 Ryan Ryan I am Legend yes correct
he had a dog so you know get a good boy
with them in the movie yeah woman and a
child comes in and also there's more
people on earth it's just New York City
that's a chance getting in that's
getting an additional point for guessing
clerks correctly ok so shout-out to
y'all in the chat okay here we go next
one is whoever wins we lose hater hater
that's alien vs. predator yeah yeah ok
an adventure 65 million years in the
making
hater Haner Jurassic Park corrects
Jurassic Park Ryan come on man out my
dad worked on that - he'd be embarrassed
about me you're doing great
alright we're collecting donations we
still have about 15 minutes left in this
stream so please donate what you can to
black lives matter or cove in nineteen
relief the links are in the description
alright go bid if you want me to win
donate to black lives matter if you want
Meg to win oh my god donate to both or
donate to funny wants me to win yeah a
lot of my friends came through all right
here we go next one a romantic comedy
with zombies meg Meg warm body
no that's a good guess really alternate
tagline this September aim for the head
man
Zombieland no Raj oh that was my guess
oh good
hey nur that was also my guess Ryan do
you have a guess romantic comedy zombies
this September oh no all right let's see
if the chat gets it I know what it is
now I think let's see I guess that's
probably after 2010 a romantic comedy
with zombies or this September aim for
the head the correct answer is Shaun of
the Dead which was Harley Pettitte got
it all right Shaun of the Dead a
romantic comedy between Simon Pegg and
Nick engine groans got it - sorry yep
okay yep so you both got it so the chat
gets it with 18 points total correct
right now all right here we go next one
on the air unaware Rochelle Rochelle
German chef correct Truman Show for the
class of 1998 the last night of high
school is the first night of the rest of
their lives Rochelle I just want to say
the faculty again just in case married
right I think that's it Ryan can't
hardly wait that is correct it's can't
hardly wait I love that movie and has a
really good soundtrack all right here we
go
earth it was fun while it lasted this
could be anything
[Laughter]
Matt break into electric Boogaloo no
Ryan what do you say oh my getting
correct it is that's a good that's a
good guest here
hopefully this I break into guys right
a game for those who seeks to find a way
to leave their world behind Ryan but
Ryan
Jumanji correct it is Jumanji coming up
alright nice planet we'll take it yeah
Matt Mars Attacks correct Mars Attacks
damn it Josh where's next gonna come
back good
alright next one you'll laugh you'll cry
you'll hurl painter painter Wayne's
World
party time excellent 55 points for Chris
alright very matter-of-fact she's
watched Blade Runner 20 49 good job
dinky Joe for getting it correct in the
twitch chat all right next one people
should not be afraid of their
governments government should be afraid
of their people Joe Joe V for Vendetta
that is correct it is V for Vendetta
okay and there will be greed there will
be vengeance painter painter there will
be blood that is correct
all right six students are about to find
out their teachers really are from
another planet Rochelle six students I
just had to sneak one more in there I'm
really sorry I'm not sorry how do I love
thee let me count the ways
meg Meg 10 Things I Hate About You
correct a great film
all right um are you watching closely
meg Meg The Prestige nailed it is quite
the film Harley thank you for screaming
the faculty in the chest act against me
in many ways back where I can it's just
the inside of my brain
here we go next one their crime is
curiosity their crime is curiosity Ryan
Ryan batteries not included spike
Spiegel got it in the chat it is hackers
[Laughter]
angel you're very welcome for including
10 Things I Hate About You love that
movie all right
yeah sorry guys that was hackers after
700 years of doing what he was built for
he'll discover what he was meant for
Brooke Ivers out Rochelle Bicentennial
man no Ryan Ryan wall-e correct it is
Wally Oh Matt come on come on my son
isn't like long at all
oh you can erase someone from your mind
getting them out of Eckhart Meg that is
correct Meg good job
Touche Meg I can never tied come on Meg
you got this I'm going for it okay yes
the poster tagline is killer looks the
alternate tag line is I think my mask of
sanity is about to slip
aimer painter face-off
know the shot Ryan to die for incorrect
good guess I like that movie thanks guys
yeah I think my mask of sanity is about
to slip or killer looks
I hope it's demolition man spec Spiegel
guess the white chicks that is incorrect
I have to return some videotapes anyone
he kind of rewind
Lyle himself got it in the YouTube chat
in his American Psycho thank you oh my
god looks Dustin also said American
Psycho good job good call good job and
dissection got it in the twitch chat all
right great nut up or shut up Matt Matt
Zombieland yep nailed it next one his
fear began when he woke up alone his
terror began when he realized he wasn't
meg Meg 28 days later correct yes I'm
here for you it's fine I'm glad what
have you got
alright here we go
next one they took his daughter he'll
take their lives Ryan Joe bacon correct
coming free man it is tough
the greatest fairy tale never told meg
Meg Shrek
that is correct how close their Megan
record I think I'm writing um Mike's
losing by one point we have seven
minutes left
in this stream we are winding down with
this lightning around but you still have
time to donate so please donate using
the links in the description below for
black lives matter or for Cova nineteen
relief and thank you so much for all
that I've donated and thank you to all
of you who've been hanging out with us
it's been a really fun trivia stream
with all of you and you guys have been
killing it in the chat getting those
points 20 points for chat right now so I
am out $40 and so is CBS so that's great
I'm very happy about that all right
okay next one is they bring you the news
so you don't have to get it yourself
Rochelle Rochelle anchorman that is
correct
[Laughter]
twice the fun double the trouble
Matt Matt The Parent Trap yes I was
hoping someone would guess one of the
Olsen twins movie kids but they're new
york minute a new york yes all right
on to the next he used to write for a
living now he's writing to stay alive
yeah matt in the mouth of madness
incorrect ryan ryan misery corrected his
misery 30 points ryan dad also worked on
that guys i'm back
you are the worst winner of that
your dad has worked on at least half the
movies we talking about I know I'm
horrible oh here we go the next one is
when Kevin's family left for vacation
I forgot Oh Joe that's home alone and
I'm the head of meg I swear to God angel
groves guess it takes two for The Parent
Trap that's what I was hoping for I was
hoping for some Olsen twins thank you
for coming through all right next one is
the world's most dangerous cop the
world's most razors yes painter
demolition man yeah we he loves that
film I have been waiting the entire game
for demolition man warrior legend King
meg Meg King Arthur mm-hmm
hater Braveheart no warrior legend King
Brian Brian gladiator let's see if the
chat gets it for your legend King I mean
it could be but this specific poem DB is
not that movie it's very obviously pop
star never stop never stop it movie was
not in the time span but it's also
timeless yeah they're guessing
Braveheart in the chat that is incorrect
dissection got it Scorpion King Oh
so the checkout it chat has 21 points
all right here we go the greatest
adventure of all is finding our place in
the circle of life
Dana Jeff tanner
The Lion King that is correct all right
50% warrior 50% lover 100% Chihuahua
Matt Matt Beverly Hills Chihuahua added
that to this list of questions that's
for him all right I think I'm fired
after answering that I can't wait for
all of our Beverly Hills Chihuahua
retrospective cons the anniversary look
into it two friends are about to cut one
Hollywood big shot down to size
Matt Matt big fat liar yeah it is Wow I
am nailing kids release from a time when
I was a late teen getting these great
job a chilling new comedy in full
meander vision a met Haner Encino man
that is correct it is Encino man I just
need one more so at least we can be tied
is it over yet are we Donnie yep -
laughing Ryan Chris let's stop talking
let my commander know sex clothes
popularity whatever no bridge oh Mean
Girls
no yeah we all know yes one more left
which one if he's gonna win they tied up
yeah that is correct they are tied with
21 points each G and the chat also has
21 points here we go guys they perform
for royalty and entertain millions the
world over but now they're making a
movie so Rochelle its spice world baby
baby
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
thank you so much to everyone who has
donated during the stream we really
appreciate the donations we appreciate
all of you hanging out please check out
all the stuff that we do on GameSpot and
GameSpot universe and yeah thanks 10 for
more charity streams that we have going
on this week let's talk about the scores
before we go Chris obviously one he's
got 59 points Matt got 37 points and
then in third was Ryan with 30 points
and then the check at 21 points so I
will be donating 21 dollars to black
lives matter and donating $21 to kovat
and having both of those matched by bike
on CBS so thank you guys in the chat for
answering all those questions and have a
great day and come back for more of our
charity streams at 12 p.m. Pacific all
week long bye guys later guys ice up
your life
[Music]